¿cómo rompes con estos mitos?
Porque ni siquiera necesitas ser médico para decir que el periodo no es tóxico.
Si lo fuera no se implantaría un embrión en esa ponzoña tóxica.
Y si todas tuviésemos esa "menotoxina" secreta,
podríamos echar a perder las cosechas y la leche.
(Risas)
¿Por qué no usamos nuestros poderes X-Femeninos para conseguir
el derecho a voto antes?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Incluso ahora cuando tuiteo sobre la diarrea menstrual,
como haría cualquiera,
(Risas)
menciono que afecta al 28 % de las mujeres.
Y siempre alguna chica me dice: "Pensé que era la única".
Esto muestra lo eficaz que es la cultura de la vergüenza,
que las mujeres no comparten sus experiencias.
Así que pensé:
"¿Qué pasaría si supiéramos del periodo como un ginecólogo?
¿No sería genial?".
Entonces todos sabrían lo que yo sé; que la menstruación es un fenómeno único
en los mamíferos.
La mayoría de los mamíferos tienen ciclo del celo.
Los humanos, algunos primates, algunos murciélagos, la musaraña elefante
y el ratón espinoso menstruan.
Y lo que pasa con la menstruación es que el cerebro provoca que el ovario
produzca un óvulo.
Se libera estrógeno y empieza a formarse el revestimiento interior del útero,
célula sobre célula, como los ladrillos.
¿Y qué pasa si haces un muro de ladrillos sin suficiente cemento?
Pues que es inestable.
Así que, ¿qué pasa cuando ovulas?
Liberas una hormona llamada progesterona, que es progestacional, prepara el útero.
Hace como el cemento que une ladrillos.
También provoca algunos cambios
para que el revestimiento sea más acogedor para la implantación.
Si no se produce el embarazo,
(Uush)
el revestimiento se desprende,
se produce el sangrado de los capilares
y eso es el periodo.
Siempre encuentro este punto muy interesante.
Porque con el ciclo del celo
el indicio final de que el interior del útero está listo
realmente viene con el embrión.
Pero con la menstruación, esa elección la hace el ovario.
Como si la elección estuviese codificada en nuestra zona reproductiva.
(Ovación y aplausos)
Bien, ahora ya sabemos por qué sangramos.
Y es una cantidad considerable.
Son de 30 a 90 mililitros de sangre.
Lo que equivale de 1 a 3 onzas.
Y a veces más.
Muchas veces parece ser más, lo sé.
¿Por qué tenemos tanta sangre?
¿Y por qué esa sangre no se queda allí hasta el siguiente ciclo?
No te embarazaste, así que ¿por qué no se queda ahí?
Imaginen que cada mes se vuelva más y más abundante.
Tendríamos un tsunami de periodo.
(Risas)
No podemos reabsorberlo porque es mucho.
Y es así porque necesitamos un revestimiento uterino grueso
por una razón específica.
El embarazo conlleva un esfuerzo biológico muy grande en nuestro cuerpo.
Existe la mortalidad materna, el estrago de amamantar
y criar a un niño hasta que se independice.
Y la evolución--
(Risas)
Eso dura más para algunas de nosotras.
La evolución entiende sobre la relación riesgo-beneficio.
Y quiere aumentar los chances de un buen resultado.
¿Y cómo hace eso?
Se intenta obtener los mejores embriones.
¿Y cómo haces eso?
Los haces trabajar y les das obstáculos.
En lo que va del milenio de evolución,
ha sido como una carrera armamentística en el útero,
con el revestimiento volviéndose cada vez más grueso
y el embrión más invasivo hasta llegar a esta tregua
con el revestimiento uterino que tenemos.
Así que tenemos este revestimiento grueso que tiene que salir,
¿y cómo dejamos de sangrar?
Detenemos el sangrado de nariz con presión y si nos cortamos la pierna también.
Detenemos el sangrado aplicando presión.
Cuando menstruamos, el revestimiento uterino
libera sustancias que se transforman en químicos llamados prostaglandinas
y otros mediadores de la inflamación que hacen que el útero se contraiga
y ejerza presión sobre esos vasos sanguíneos
para detener el sangrado.
También pueden alterar el flujo sanguíneo hacia el útero y causar inflamación.
Lo que causa más dolor.
Y entonces te preguntas: ¿cuánta presión es generada?
Se han realizado estudios en los que mujeres increíbles
voluntariamente se han dejado colocar catéteres de presión intrauterina
durante todo el periodo--
Hay que agradecerles porque no sabríamos esto de no ser por ellas.
Y es muy importante saberlo
porque la presión generada en el útero durante la menstruación
es de 120 milímetros de mercurio.
Se preguntarán qué significa eso.
Es la presión que se genera durante la segunda fase del parto
cuando estás pujando.
(Suspiros)
Así es.
Para las que no han tenido parto natural es similar a cuando el tensiómetro
no está tan apretado como al principio pero aun así aprieta y quieres sacártelo.
Ahora cambia la percepción, ¿no?
Si piensan en el dolor menstrual,
si una chica falta a la escuela porque está en la segunda fase del parto pujando,
no le diríamos débil.
Le diríamos: "Dios mío, ¿sobreviviste?".
(Risas)
Y no le negaríamos calmantes a las mujeres con dolores típicos del parto, ¿no?
Es importante que hablemos del dolor como "típico" y no como "normal"
porque cuando decimos que es "normal" es más fácil de ignorarlo.
Debemos decir que es "típico" y que debemos hablar de ello.
Existen maneras en las que podemos aliviar el dolor menstrual.
Una manera es utilizando un estimulador nervioso transcutáneo
que manda impulsos eléctricos a los nervios y músculos,
y se puede usar bajo la ropa.
Nadie sabe bien cómo funciona
pero creemos que puede estar relacionado con la teoría de la compuerta
y contrarresta la irritación.
Es como cuando te lastimas y te frotas.
Las vibraciones llegan más rápido al cerebro que el dolor.
Otra manera es tomando medicamentos como los antiinflamatorios no esteroideo.
Estos bloquean la liberación de protaglandinas
que reducen el dolor menstrual al 80 % de las mujeres,
la cantidad de sangrado a un 30-40 % y la diarrea menstrual.
Por último, los anticonceptivos
que hacen que el revestimiento uterino se vuelva más delgado,
por lo que se producen menos protaglandinas
y al disminuir el sangrado disminuye el dolor.
Si todo esto te falla--
Es importante usar esa palabra porque no es que nosotras fallamos
sino que el tratamiento nos falla.
Si todo esto te falla, puedes ser inmune
al efecto de los antiinflamatorios no esteroideos.
Todavía no lo tenemos bien en claro pero existen razones complejas
por las que esos medicamentos no son efectivos para algunas mujeres.
Existe otra razón por la que puedes tener periodos tan dolorosos.
Puedes tener endometriosis,
que consiste en el crecimiento del revestimiento uterino
en la cavidad pélvica,
causando inflamación y el desarrollo de tejido cicatrizal.
Existen otros mecanismos que todavía no entendemos
ya que existe la posibilidad de que el umbral de dolor sea diferente
debido a la complejidad de algunos mecanismos biológicos.
Pero eso solo lo sabremos si lo hablamos.
Saber cómo funciona tu cuerpo no debería considerarse un acto feminista.
No debería--
(Aplausos)
Pedir ayuda cuando estás sufriendo no debería considerarse un acto feminista.
La era de los tabús menstruales terminó.
(Ovación y aplausos)
Para ver más charlas visite TED.com.
El único error es haber logrado convencer a la mitad de la población
de que los responsables biológicos que perpetúan la especie
y nos dan todo lo que tenemos son de alguna manera sucios y tóxicos.
Y no lo voy a tolerar.
(Aplausos)
¿Cómo rompemos con esta creencia?
Con conocimiento.
Gracias.
(Ovación y aplausos)